we we we've got a uh breaking news from
project veritas oh boy all right now
this uh this story actually came out
right around the time we went live
this is crazy stuff
project veritas has released expose fda
part one
fda executive officer on hidden camera
reveals future coveted policy quote
biden wants to inoculate as many people
as possible have to get an annual shot
they say
food fda executive officer christopher
cole inadvertently revealed that his
agency will eventually announce that
annual covet 19 vaccinations will become
policy
cole is an executive officer heading up
the agency's counter measures and
initiatives which plays a critical role
in ensuring that drugs vaccines and
other measures to counter infectious
diseases and viruses are safe he made
the revelations on hidden camera to an
undercover reporter
cole indicates that annual covid 19
shots isn't probable but certain when
pushed on how he knows an annual shot
will become policy call states just from
everything i've heard the fda are not
are not going to not approve it the
footage which is part of a two-part
series in the fda also contains sound
bites from coal but the financial
incentives pharmaceutical companies like
pfizer have to get
have to get the vaccine approved saying
quote it'll be recurring fountain
recurring fountain of revenue it might
not be that much initially but it'll
recurring if they can
if they can get every person required at
an annual vaccine that is a recurring
return of money going into their company
quote they're going they're all approved
under an
emergency just because it's not as
impactful as some of other approvals
really an emergency for kids
so there's a lot more to this
um i've seen a little bit of it
but it seems this guy at least
believes uh
it's your yearly coverage recurring
fountain of revenue monetizing
your body with inoculations dude medical
subscription services biden wants to
inoculate everyone is that what that guy
said everyone biden has said he has said
that himself i figured which i forget
which press conference it was but his
solution to this covet problem was we
have to vaccinate everyone in this
country and then we have to vaccinate
the rest of the world that was his that
was his way out of this i'm just
struggling to find the uh the exact
question i remember that i remember that
he did say that right okay all right
thanks for doing a little sanity check
on me there because i remember that yes
no he said that that was his one year
i think
but i do remember writing that yeah no
he said it that's his goal that's that's
how he thinks the virus is shut down
look up the definition the word
inoculate and think that joe biden wants
to do this to you it's so to implant
microorganisms or infectious material
into a culture medium
to introduce a serum vaccine or an
antigenic substance into the body of a
person oh let's say it like that yeah
this third one is to implant
microorganisms or infections i mean
that's basically you know you put you
put a little bit of dangerous stuff in
the body so it jacks up an immune
response and then you become immune over
time is the idea but forcing it on
people top-down medicine it's crazy what
did it say is reoccurring revenue is
that what yeah
there is a fountain it'll literally
monetize your body the experimental
service yes man you gotta you gotta look
these pharmaceutical companies pay big
for sponsoring these big corporate media
they they spend a lot of money lobbying
they make a lot of contributions how
many pharmaceutical uh commercials ran
on the super bowl you guys get a number
google hangout oh yeah i'm curious now
i know that all these big media
companies are brought to you by pfizer
because i saw that supercomputer
that's a great super cut
in the meantime i want to say so the old
tried phrase is all roads lead to rome i
wonder if the phrase for our culture
that survives for centuries is all roads
lead to alex jones
yeah yes
is that right through alex well there's
through alex's jokes i love that
there was that story the other day about
the blm activists who tried to
assassinate the democrat there
and people were pointing out that alex
jones had said several months ago that
there's going to be attacks on democrats
to justify gun control and harsh
measures against the people
i got to say
if you if you throw spaghetti spaghetti
at enough clocks eventually they'll tell
you the right time or yeah you know
whatever twice a day whatever yeah yeah
throw spaghetti no you throw spaghetti
at a bunch of clocks and eventually some
of them will just splatter into the
right
time yeah yeah so if you make if you're
making predictions on everything
eventually people can be like
theoretically i think of a million
monkeys of a million typewriters will
eventually write hamlet right right
right as the saying goes
hamlet no that did that to that demo it
was a mayor
yeah
yeah
mayoral candidate mayoral candidate
imagine if that was a white guy that did
something like that that story is crazy
by the way too
i watched a press conference apparently
he walked in and they're like can we
help you and he pulled the gun out from
a few feet away and fired and missed wow
it's funny because i saw a lot of people
on twitter saying i call bs how'd he
miss and i'm like that sounds like
someone who's never fired yeah handgun
yes it's like the waukesha stuff just
gets not a moving talk
right under the rug did the guy see was
he looking them in the eyes like was the
guy able to
i don't know he said that the guy walked
in and just you know pulled a gun
pointed it but uh people who think you
can't miss have clearly never fired a
handgun very easy to miss the handgun
very easy people when they fire when
they squeeze their hand they move the
gun in certain ways they don't realize
it
and so what ends up happening is they
usually point left or right or if you're
right-handed you'll point left and down
or something like that at least that's
what i was told when i went to the range
the first time and that happened to me
telling me how to shoot properly but
yeah i think
it's just getting crazy out there
for a variety of reasons when you have
these disparate factions of people that
are all extreme
no cohesion just
eventually
well i am i am concerned because there
does seem to be a shortage of actual
right-wing terrorism which means that
you're going to need to find a way to
meet the demand
you know what i mean like if people
aren't being violent that's what makes
me think that the this cache of guns in
canada might possibly be some kind of
bad really truly might be a bad actor
trying to make them look bad trying to
plant this on them and make it look like
they're trying to plan some kind of
violent good thing this is a well-known
guy i mean this is an activist who did
this could you imagine well okay he's
been arrested for the blm guy
considering they were there and they
watched him do it i think they got the
right guy rest assured the the uh fbi is
on that oh yeah yeah they're on it
they're on it they're working on it
really hard it happened well in uh
michigan you know they had outstanding
results the right-wing terrorism will
happen
there's nothing bad going on right now
why what's wrong with reality that
something we can't figure out what's
wrong like something's bad i have a bad
feeling i can't see anything wrong so
they go out like this is the mentality
if something's not wrong then something
must be wrong because life is bad like
these people live to their law
enforcement they go around looking for
people breaking laws
and if the people are breaking laws and
they make up new ways to get them
yeah i think it's i think it's a good
strategy to easily emotionally
manipulate a lot of people very quickly
because if you could
bring unity with like millions of people
with a centralized enemy i think that's
essentially what trump was um you could
really get a lot of people unified for a
specific cause and i think you see this
happen throughout history all the time
where there's a common enemy that the
people all have and i think the far left
does a really good job at doing this
they do a really good job at demonizing
their opponents they do a really good
job at slandering them and painting them
as these are the people that are going
to destroy your life the white
supremacist the neo-nazi it's always
this fear everything's that's why
everything's a phobia everything is a
phobia homophobia islamophobia they just
slapped phobia to it and we unify the
entire base and they're out there
busting people's doors down it it works
i like that phobia phobia if you don't
like a sport you're you're soccerphobic
phobia everything's a phobia you don't
like soccer soccer fear is very powerful
with dave chappelle they uh he was uh in
opposition to this um construction that
was gonna be going on in his town so
they framed it as though he opposed
affordable housing because it's always a
dirty manipulative game they didn't ask
him why he was in opposition to it they
just said this proposal would include
affordable housing dave chappelle
threatens to pull millions of dollars
out of town in opposition to affordable
housing i i've covered enough of those
man i eye melting brain
numbing city council meetings to know
that the affordable housing that these
city councils advocate for is almost
always corrupt it never pans out it is
all about money it's all about corrupt
politicians i mean i covered anaheim
there's there's like a super corrupt
problem in anaheim because disney owns
anaheim but and and that's how these
deals go down i mean obviously dave
chappelle's no [ __ ] like he's a sharp
guy he probably saw right through the
corruption and right through the
nonsense and he went there and it's just
like i don't support this and they
panicked and then they had to smear him
so does disney actually literally own
the city of anaheim uh they they do
through back door deals because without
disney and without angel stadium anaheim
is not a city it's it's like a third
world
town
so
well basically the city council of
anaheim is never going to do anything
that's not in disney's best interests
which also puts them in the ccp's pocket
nice wow
that checks out yeah yeah oh things are
going good
sorry i just want to bring some good
news from california
sunny
maybe let california go its own way huh
yeah i think it's supposedly going to
slip down isn't it slip up into canada
at some point canada hear that canada
yeah watch out it's coming for you
when the san andreas fault yes
apparently it's slipping calgary is
sliding up they thought it was going to
fall off and disappear but i think it's
technically sliding up
maybe something like that and then it'll
go right below alaska and then connect
the you know
you know i think if california didn't
move that far north though everything
about california would change overnight
because the people who live there would
be able to handle the harsh reality not
at all
cold tundra that's one of the things
that's so awesome about the protests in
canada the truckers is there just they
could just handle that man you saw wall
street everybody turned in late november
or mid-november or whenever it was it
was cold there was a funny post where uh
some women tweeted
you know you should go out there and
spray water on their handles and freeze
them out and someone was like to think
that canadian truckers don't know how to
handle ice it shows you exactly
what's wrong with these urban you know
city urban liberal types
like yeah if there's if there's anyone i
would ask for advice in terms of i sound
my car it'd be a canadian trucker
seriously like you guys are in the cold
and you drive know anything i don't know
about tips and tricks about getting the
ice off the car and open it up they'd be
like oh yeah i got you
yeah yeah it's probably happened to you
guys winter comes around your car door
freezes shut you can't open it how do
you get in gotta get that remote start
turn the heat on right that's the secret
i was looking for how many
pharmaceutical commercials they rendered
in super bowl i cannot find this but if
anyone out there if you guys know feel
free to super chat it or leave it in the
comments if you have some ideas or links
or something because i'd like to find
out i have a feeling they were more than
last year yeah i'm sure that's non-zero
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00
pm
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you